hello everyone and welcome to what seems
to be the craziest game of round two of
the crazier Grantchester being played in
Zagreb it's a young opponent versus
Fabiana Caruana it's a really a crazy
game no no engine preparation know
anything of the sort this is real chess
and it's this game has so many
complications that it's really like I
said
or maybe I haven't not for the faint of
heart so without further ado let's check
out some of the photos as we didn't have
any from the previous video now I did
have Magnus or not that here is a Magnus
Carlsen with I don't know who the lady
is I think she's some sort of a delegate
for the Norwegian Croatian relations if
any of you do know do share in the
comments and she was supposed to make
the first move for Magnus in his game
against Anand yesterday but instead she
just gave Magnus a big kiss that of
course is a joke
of course she made the first move the
kiss was just a bonus or maybe she's
just whispering something to easier I
have no idea and we have a very nice
photo of this game here there you have
it Fabi and and nip Oh a nice view
through the audience so let's just enjoy
that for a moment and and now we can
check out the game so we have a Sicilian
game and it's well sort of a World Chess
Championship line but today then then
they take the game is somewhere else
we're c5 so Sicilian defense Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 and d4 we have C
captures Knight captures Knight to f6
and now comes the Knight to c3 and here
he 5 so the knight has to decide where
to go of course the knight will go to b5
with d6 the same as in the World Chess
Championship match 95 Knight captures it
captures and now you can decide whether
you want to go to be 8 or to e7
Magnus tried both here for this game
Knepper goes in the night to be 8 and
this will be following the game a lot of
games have been played in this line
recently as you'll see
Knepper goes a4 with Bishop to e7 and
here
Bishop to e2 is basically the main move
Knepper already had this position
against Magnus cos and in the other
books no way championship this year also
neppo the dead game was a draw but
interestingly
Seymour Schulich ruff also had this
position against Magnus Carlsen no I
think MVL have it against Carson in the
Norway championship and neppo had it
somewhere in the Blitz section of the of
the Abidjan côte d'ivoire tournament but
both of those games ended in a draw and
interestingly Peter Svidler also had
this position against Caruana in the
grand caches classic and also Bishop to
e2 was played and also their game ended
in a draw but here Knepper goes Bishop
to b2 and it's very interesting already
unmoved ten of this very very analyzed
line we have a completely new game so
how will Carr wanna deal with it let's
just see the idea is once this Knight is
Andre you want to pull this pawn to e5
and once the knight is under attack you
want to place the a3 and you want your
Bishop to be guarding the d a5 pawn and
also it's a very devious way of going
after the d6 pawn with Bishop to b4
which you'll see later
so Caruana castles with a 5 by neppo as
we've already mentioned a 693 now the
bishop nicely guards the a 5-1 and
Knight to d7 with Knight to c4 now going
after the d6 pawn this way and f5 now
the usual way black will play this line
and Bishop to b4 so the d6 pawn is
pressured you have to defend it somehow
Fabi chooses rook to f6 which defends
the pond and also is ready to transfer
the rook if needed to start an attack
against the Kings side but there is also
a very interesting line that starts with
F 4 and just giving up the pawn here as
you will win it back for example Bishop
captures Bishop captures Knight captures
and now you can go Knight to f6 and the
Queen and the knight are attacking the
d5 pawn so you either move the knight
and lose the pawn or if you want to
protect the pawn you have to capture on
c8 rook captures and then c4 okay you're
guarding the pawn but now efore is
coming and with your Kings still being
in the center seems like a very
dangerous position to play obviously if
Bobby decided it it wasn't the way to go
but okay after Bishop to b4 5e goes
group to f6 he defends the d6 pawn and
now Queen to d2 just developing the
Queen and maybe
even preparing to Castle queenside we
have looked the g6 by Fabi
now hindering the development of the
light square bishop as the g2 point is
under pressure with g3 and now
efore in some lines making room for the
knight on e5 but also it's a very
dangerous pawn with Nepos King still
being in the center of the board
III could come at any point it would
could be could be dangerous with h4 by
by nipple at preparing h5 and here with
b5 pushing the knight back or inviting
White's to capture on Poisson and
usually when white pushes this pawn all
the way to a5 it's almost never a good
idea to push her pawn to b5 to allow
this on passant capture because you will
just be left with with a weak a sex pawn
but okay we have Knight captures and b6
and now Knight to a5 going after this c6
square and there's not much you can do
about it Fabi plays Bishop to d7 but
Knepper first castles Queen side and he
will go Knight to c6 either way because
he will either have a monster night or
after Fabi captures he will get a very
nice pass pawn on c6 so Bishop to f6 now
as
nepo Castle queenside Fabi now wants to
transfer his pieces to attack the Queen
side with Knight to c6 and now you don't
want to capture it you would get well if
you capture then you get a very nice
pass pawn and also the d6 pawn is
attacked three times so not something
you want to do so we have Queen to d8 by
Fabi and now comes King to b1 and again
here you have to decide what to do here
we have a very interesting line a Fabi
played King to h8 but we have a very
interesting line that starts with E 3
and now white would have to decide what
to do here and it's not all that clear
either you trade Queens which and screen
captures air captures and now you can go
Knight capture some d5 you remove the
defender of the night and c6 and then of
course you don't capture but rather
Bishop to c4 check first
and then after Bishop captures you will
get Bishop captures on d5 Bishop
captures rook captures and then rook
captures and g3 rook captures on f5 and
you get to this position where
everything is pretty much traded down
but the bishops are of the same color
another thing you could do after e3 is
just play f captures on e3 you say I
don't want to trade anything but then
black starts an attack with Knight a for
your B two ponies under attack and here
you go Bishop e3 you defend it but then
again rook captures in g3 black gets a
lot of play so this is one way
Bobby could have treated this position
but he first decides for King to h8 now
neppo no longer allows III we have h h5
pushing the row back rook to h6 and now
Queen to e3 blocking the pawn and also
attacking the knight here with Knight to
a4 now defending the b2 point and now no
longer can you defend it with the bishop
day 3 this would be this would be bad
because after captures and captures
black will just capture and b2 and after
you capture guru kb8
the bishop is pinned and you will just
you would just grab it and enjoy a nice
position
so after Knight to a4 we have c3 and now
comes Luke captures on h5 which isn't
the best idea for for Caruana here if
you want you know it's a really
complicated position but if you want
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it the best idea for Caruana in
this position just have a nice zip of my
water for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent finder of great moves in
complicated positions and for those who
just want to enjoy the show Bishop
captures on c6 is the move you want to
play because after D captures and Queen
captures what do you play here well you
do have to play something rook captures
on d6 is the best move and then you get
Queen to b7
the threat is a5 and there is not much a
white can do about it whatever you play
let's say play Bishop e2 a normal move
you get a 5 and then after the shot a 3
you get Knight captures on c3 and here
white just falls apart
as of course the point is pin so not
much to do there and well it's it's
really a good position to be in so far
we did not go for that although it seems
to be great but it's really a disgusting
line if you agree
far we went for rook captures on h5 he
grabs a pawn and offers a trade but on
the other hand he also gives a nipple
and semi-open age file for a to use for
attack with look after screen captures
and Tao Bishop to e2 also nipple gets to
develop his bishop with an attack on the
Queen Queen back to a eight and now King
to see to Nippon knows that there's a
lot of pressure going on against the c3
pawn so the King will also help out in
defending it with h6 by Fabi getting
some breathing room for his King again
and now once again what do you play here
well you have to decide what to do you
could go for Bishop captures on d6 seems
like it's a free pawn but then again you
get Bishop captures captures and Queen
captures and again your queen side will
be under attack for the rest of the game
so not worth it to grab this pawn here
Fabi went Queen to f4 and sorry never
went Queen to f4 f4 with ideas that if
this Bishop ever captures then you can
eliminate the f5 point and here Bobby
played a5 which is a super interesting
move and it is at this moment that
everyone became interested in this game
because he's just offering a pawn and
okay you do get an open file for your
rook but still if you don't have any
ideas and what to do after this it's
well it's just a free pawn neppo grabs
it and it's it's actually a very good
sacrifice but what's interesting is that
here after sacrificing the pawn Fabi
went into a deep thing I think around 17
minutes which can be odd at times as
first you want to figure out what you
want to do and only then sacrifice the
pawn but here Fabi sacrifices the pawn
and then you know makes sure of what
he's about to do and again feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
best idea for black in this position as
it's really insane I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
are able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent mover of bishops and
for those who who just want to enjoy the
show Bishop to b5 this is the strongest
move you attack the bishop on e2 and now
what do you do here you can well you
don't want to capture and ow
the black queen to come into the attack
you can defend it with queen III which
is not all that great after Queen III
you get night the c5 and now of course
if you capture then the hand the night
here becomes a week but there there are
other problems for example Bishop to a4
check with win material so here your
best bet is to play a bit of capers on
c5 and after Bishop to a4 check you can
block it with b3 but then you get a rope
captures here your Bishop is still under
attack so you can either move it or
capture here but after let's say Bishop
captures you will get Queen captures on
a4 and now you're you're you're done for
whatever you play yeah if you go this
way you're getting checkmated and if you
go to a dark square Bishop g5 just wins
the Queen so this would have been best
Bishop to b5 and if you just block it
with c4 well then you're beat upon is no
longer defended so first black will
attack the Queen Queen e5 and verse 55
and after Queen t3 you're just gonna go
back with the bishop and then a White's
pawn structure in front of the King is
completely ruined you're just gonna
really enjoy playing this game so this
was the best course of action for Fabi
but he decided to go for a more
complicated line Knight captures on c3
and now he asks nappa what do you want
to do it seems very unnatural to capture
with the bishop as after Bishop
recaptures the knight on a five will be
undefended but this is actually the best
course of defense for white here Bishop
captures Bishop captures and now after
King captures rook captures an a5 but
now Queen captures on d6 and although it
looks very ugly to get to have your king
and c3 it would be the the best line of
line of defense for white here never
wanted to defend everything he played B
captures and thief c3 and now of course
Fabi gets this check in rush up to a4
check with King to be one of course you
cannot go to c1 Bishop g5 still wins the
Queen so Bishop capture some d1 Bishop
captures on d1 and now Queen to b5 Fabi
continues in the strongest way possible
with some very nice threats rook
captures here is a threat as the bishop
is pinned a queen to f1 also a threat
going after the light square Bishop here
even though
Napo has two bishops for a rook it will
be very hard to get out of this with
Knight to b3 the strongest move getting
the knight out of the way and now here
is the really important question what do
you do here feel free to pause the video
and try to find the best move for Fabi
just you know give it your best
well I give it a you know for those of
you who are able to do it you are an
excellent grabber of pawns and attacker
of bishops because Queen captures on d5
is the way to go you grab a pawn which
is always nice and also it comes with an
attack on the bishop so it does look
like like there's no problem here
but Fabi decides against this and Fabi
actually plays Bishop to g5 here and
neppo just plays Queen captures on f5 so
now Napo is defending the d5 pawn and he
grabbed the pond so there's no and
there's no good explanation on why Fabi
allowed this why he didn't just capture
this and attack the bishop and only
after a nipple moves the bishop then he
can play whatever but here you have to
see what to do first we have to check if
Queen to a4 is winning because okay
Queen to a2 is the threat of checkmate
as the bishop is covering the C 1 square
but here white actually has a beautiful
defense a beautiful defense because
first you have to play f4 block the
bishop and offer on poisson to clear
this diagonal for your bishop this is
ever I mean this is what it takes to
defend this wood white and after it
captures on f3 and poisson you will play
Bishop to a5 this is the beauty here now
you block the Queen to a2 and here
there's just no way to continue the
attack rook captures an 85 seems
beautiful because if you capture the
rook then you get Queen captures anyone
with check but White has everything
covered
Queen CH check King to h7 and now push
up the C to check the reason why you had
to play a f4 and allow this on pass on
this comes with the check and after g6
you will just have a nice perpetual or
you can just play Queen to c7 check and
even win the rook here and now white
would have a better
King g8 Queen captures and just a better
position for white now as white is up a
piece so Queen today for although
seemingly deadly doesn't work and Fabi
finds the discontinuation that doesn't
make it work he plays Queen to f1
instead goes after this Bishop and again
there there's only one way to defend
this for Nepal for example if you go
king c2 you just lose the game
ruk a to check King b1 rook captures
here the Queen is under attack the
bishop is under attack you would be
completely lost here so never plays
Queen to g4 he defends the bishop and
now we have looked the f8 by 5 is still
trying to get this rook F doing and here
a brilliant defense by nipple King bee
to just putting the king in the line of
fire unpinning the bishop he allows rook
captures an f2 with check and now he
blocks rush of the c2 and now what do
you do here again I have to ask you to
pause the video one more time because
there is only one good continuation here
for black and you will you know it will
be nice for you to to practice how how
to feel in a certain position are you
better or worse or you just you know
draw so ok for those of you who found it
congratulations you are an excellent
Assessor of positions and for those if
you just want to enjoy the show
push up the c1 check is the best move
but it's super hard to find and it's
basically move that forces the draw
because after Knight captures now you
play queen g2 and you attack the bishop
here so if white doesn't want to allow
this first you play Queen c8 check after
King h7 you get well you have to allow
Queen rook captures here so you play
king b3 just so the capture doesn't come
with check and now black has to capture
or he just down material so after you
capture now you get Queen to a5 check
and you will have a draw by perpetual
checking after you go let's say here
check here check here check here if you
go here then another check on the light
square you will just use this diagonal
to keep checking the black King so after
bush of the c2 Bobby did not play Bishop
the c1 check he wanted to go for the win
he played Queen to c4 but now we have
Queen to east
pineapple going after this point here
and now Fabi really doesn't have a good
move here why we played Bishop to f6 now
pinning the pawn here the thread is
Queen captures Bishop but neppo just
grabs a pawn Queen captures on these six
so the second point
Fabi just gave gift a nipple for no
reason and this is now not to be
forgiven now the problem is you cannot
start pushing you're a pawn if you put
something like III seems very good but
the bishop guards h7 Queen to f8 is just
made so here Fabi after going into a
deep thing not not too long but I think
as he was really really low on time he
played rook captures and c2 wanted to
eliminate this Bishop that covers the h7
square we have King captures and now
Queen to d3 check with King to be to and
now III Fabi now host get this passport
all the way but Quinta is 6 now nepo
knows that while the Queen is guarding
d1 square he can push c4 at any moment
and the bishop will also be covering d1
square so it doesn't seem very likely
that you will be Queen in your pawn here
okay yeah still can push it because of
the pin here but you want to play King
to a3 and only then push c4 so [ __ ] you
played King e2 a 4.32 and we have king
to e3 so we still can't promote it as
it's unguarded and the problem with
Queen d1 is that you just play Queen e8
check and African gauge 7 Queenie for
check King Tate rate and now you push c4
and everything is everything is fine
there's no Queenie the pawn the bishop
and queen guard d1 square so here Fabi
played Bishop to g5 and now we have d6
Nepos starts pushing his own passport as
well we have Queen a6 check King Tubby
to and now Queen back to d3
but d7 navona also threatens check and
d8 to window Queen
so King to h7 and now finally see for
grabbing hold of the e1 square Bishop f6
check even that is not a problem King to
a3 we have Queen to c2 and it does seem
dangerous but even Queen to be 2 does
nothing as the King can always escape to
a4 and the knight does an excellent job
of guarding the C 1 and a 1 squares at
which the black Queen can use to deliver
checks
so here never played one more move and
it was after that moved the fabric
resigns here never played Queen captures
on f6 and he laughed at Fabi for having
no pieces left on the board and Fabi
said yes you are correct and it was in
this position that Fabiana Khurana
resigned the game so he resigned as
after G captures you just get another
Queen into the game and bishops toga
covers the e1 square so there is no
point in continuing here and like we
said the night covers a1 c1 so there are
no checks it's all excellent here for
white so yeah and we don't have one more
photo it's a photo of the two of them
talking about the game analyzing it
after it's over you can see neppo having
33 minutes on the clock whereas Fabi has
only 25 seconds so the the last few
decisions well by last few decisions I
mean the the last 15 moves by Fabi were
made in in severe time trouble sure
that's pretty much the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank our
girls OVF and mihai bata for
contributing to my channel think we
ought to really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
see our think all for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this sagar
branch a store checking open or
suggestions and if we really catch a
moment continuing the capablanca saga
some simultaneously with the
Grantchester so I think you'll I will
see you soon have an excellent rest of
your day